We have to understand that every rule that
gets written has a cost.
I don't think parents get that under the headline
'We're gonna keep your children safe.
We're gonna protect the kids.'
that that's really code for 'We're taking
your rights away.'
Hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and today
we're talking with Abby Schachter, she is
a long-time journalist and the author of the
fabulous new book
'No Child Left Alone: Getting the Government out of Parenting.'
Abby, thanks for talking to us.
It's great to be here.
The book is all about how government at all
levels and other kind of butt-insky groups
are getting more and more involved in the
raising of children, of child-rearing.
Give some of the most exemplary illustrations
of just how annoying and frustrating this
is, and why don't you start with your daycare
experience that you start the book with.
Right.
So I didn't set out to be a radical, I just
wanted my kids swaddled at day care.
But that isn't okay with the state of Pennsylvania,
and it's where i drew the line
and got into this subject.
We have four children, they've all gone to
state licensed day care, there were a huge
number of rules and regulations that were
annoying but we- I lived with them.
And then the fourth one was born and we brought
him to day care at nine weeks of age and they
said 'What do you want us to know about him?'
and I said 'One thing:
please swaddle him, tightly.'
And that means wrapping the baby in a kind
of blanket.
So that they sleep easier.
Like baby Jesus, right?
It's been done for thousands of years.
It was the only parenting book we actually
read and followed: doctor Harvey Karp, I'm
a big proselytizer for him, happiest baby
on the block.
All our children sleep because of swaddling.
So that was it, that's all I wanted.
And the day care said 'We need a doctor's
note because the state of Pennsylvania otherwise
bans swaddling in day care.'
So I said 'That is crazy, I've never heard
of such a thing.'
and I-
They pushed you too far.
They pushed me too far, I just said 'That
is it' and I said 'I'm donning my cape.
I am now captain mommy, I'm taking charge.'
And I thought 'oh okay I'll just get the doctor's
note.'
I actually started off thinking this will
be a reasonable, reasonably easy thing to
get done and it turns out it's not.
Because some of the same people who are pushing
this kind of overly broad definitions of safety
and lack of acceptance of risk are the people
who- the doctors, pediatricians, go to to
get opinions for how they should advise their
patients.
So that is, I mean, one clear case of government
regulation or, you know, some kind of authority
coming in and saying 'No.
You gotta do it this way in this circumstance.'
What are a couple of others?
So the worst example are the dozens of cases
of the state coming and taking custody of
children who are morbidly obese.
These are heartbreaking stories.
The family tends to be unhealthy, not just
the child and they are really unhealthy but
the state says that the best they can do is
remove a child from it's family, causing other
damage, but they're gonna try and 'solve'
in quotes this one problem-
And that's the super fat kid?
That's the super fat kid.
Does it work?
Is it effective at least?
Well, it depends who you talk to.
There are lots of doctors who say 'just force
them to have surgery.'
I mean, bariatric surgery, a teenager could
live a much longer life then
trying to change behavior.
Behavior modification is actually very difficult
to achieve successfully and yet the state
is basically saying 'That's what we're gonna
do.'
Yeah, I was gonna say, I mean, that's hard
for individuals, you know, who are really
dedicated to but then to get a bureaucrat
to do, to make somebody else pay attention.
You also talk about the war on fun and the
kind of play deficit.
Right, so there's- there are all kinds of
experts who will talk about, Peter Gray talks
about this a lot, you know, the deficit of
unsupervised, imaginative,
free play amongst kids.
Some of that is parents, they don't wanna
let the kids out of the house
so they over-schedule them, okay.
But if you don't have recess at school, which
a lot of parents are fighting for, if you
ban certain activities, sledding in a public
playground, running in a public space, pushing
other kids on the swing.
So all kinds of activities end up being banned,
not because the government comes along or
the school system comes along and says 'hey
we don't want these kids to have any fun.'
But they are defining a problem and they are
solving it in their easiest, sort of, overly
broad way which is: we're just gonna ban it.
So why is this kinda stuff happening now?
I've been writing about the different experience
of childhood, you know, from my childhood
to my kid's childhood for twenty years.
My kids are now 22 and 14 and in the 90s when
i started thinking about this stuff I realized,
wow their lives are so different than the
one I grew up in and mine was on another planet
from my parents.
So why is this kind of structure happening?
Is it simply that in two income households
both parents are away and you put your kids
into institutionalized settings more?
Is it the ridiculous over-estimations of risk,
what's going on here?
I think that it's a combination of things.
I think there is been several media hysterias
having to do with children.
Right?
Abduction was one, and this is a mythology
that has so taken root that we have had low
crime rates for 15 years and I still get people
reacting to my book saying
'But the kid could get abducted.'
you know?
Why does that linger so long? and how does
it
continue to inform policy and kind of mental maps?
Well, because they went- we moved from abductions,
let's say, to the hysteria over satanism at
day care, right?
That was the 90s.
I would have paid extra.
If I coulda gotten my kid into the satanist
day care.
And at least if I could have done that now,
it would have been cheaper.
There would have been swaddling, I'm sure.
Satanists would swaddle!
I, that would have been a reason to try it
out.
I think that it's all these hysterias that
have taken hold and anxiety is really hard
to combat.
I mean that's really, I think that's a large
part of this.
You also talk about, you reference Philip
K Howard, the author whose best known book
is 'The Death of Common Sense.'
And he talks a lot about how people, oftentimes
in a good natured way, or a good faith way
say 'Look this is just common sense, let's
put a law or a process.'
and then it goes in a very different direction.
Is that a contributing factor here?
The kind of over-lawyering of everyday life.
The over-lawyering, I mean, look: part of
it is practical, the trial lawyers get work,
right?
If you can sue and we don't have a reform
as simple as loser pays then you have an incentive
to sue the municipality if your kid gets hurt
sledding.
And these municipalities are struggling to
pay their pensions so they don't wanna fight
a lawsuit.
They'll settle, and then they'll just ban
the activity.
So some of these critiques and in Howard's
case he's absolutely right also about the
nature of the regulation.
We don't say out value is X and therefore
we want to allow people to achieve that value
whether it be safety or reducing risk, you
find a way to do it.
What we say is, you have to have the hooks
in day care this far apart because that's
the safety standard, right?
So-
So we're not really being led by general principles
or goals it's rather being very kind of literal
and specific.
Absolutely and you see that everywhere.
And you see that with, sort of, the Consumer
Product Safety Commission, their labels, right?
They are also- There's no common sense in
their warning labels.
Because, what do they put on the warning labels
for baby seats?
Don't put this on a high surface where the
baby might fall.
I mean you would think this is common sense
right?
Instead they hounded the manufacturer of a
particular- of the Bumbo.
And now they changed the name of the product.
So now it's called the Bumbo floor seat right?
As if it was too difficult for people to understand
that it was not meant to be put up on a table
or a chair it was meant to sit on the floor
and that would be the safest place for a baby.
Well here's a challenge, is it possible, you
know, we know from looking at the results
of school tests for K through 12 students,
for, you know, going back to the early 70s
when we started doing this, we're not- the
kids aren't getting any smarter maybe parents
aren't as smart as they once were.
That's also possible.
I mean, I wouldn't put it- but I would say
that I have found some very smart parents
writing this book.
No Child Left Alone I tried to enter as many
examples of parents who, like myself, just
said 'This is the stupidest thing I've ever
heard of in my life and I wanna be left alone
to parent my own kid.'
And talk a bit about, so what is the cure?
Where do we go from here?
Because you're against the idea that there
is a kind of big switch where we can go from
insanity to sanity.
What are the types of activities, what are
the types of things that can happen to kind
of free our children and by extension free
us as parents to, you know, kind of live in
a world that is more interesting and exciting
and ultimately better for both parents and children?
So the two things that I would suggest are
one: bring the problem solving closer to the
supposed problem.
I had to go and find the people who made up
this rule about swaddling and they weren't
in my state and they weren't even accountable.
I couldn't yell at them because it wasn't
their fault they wrote a nice book of guidelines.
And the other thing I would say is that we
have to understand that every rule that gets
written has a cost.
I don't think parents get that under the headline
'We're gonna keep your children safe.
We're gonna protect the kids.'
that that's really code for 'We're taking
your rights away.'
Would you draw a connection between the way
that we treat our children when they're kind
of in, you know, K through 12 or when they're
living at home with us, would you trace a
line from that and kind of the infantilization
of kids in a way that is more than it used
to be and parents.
Because parents aren't allowed to make choices.
Is that part of what we're seeing on college
campuses when we see either administrators
or students themselves demanding a kind of
more infantile safe space in college campuses.
I mean it's hard for me to say that it's a
direct line.
But certainly there's an influence because
what you're hearing about what happens to
college kids is they get there and they don't
know how to
live in a world that isn't a safe space.
So they're demanding it because that's what
they've experienced.
If you're also coming from a place where you
were never, you never rode the city bus anywhere,
you never got anywhere on your own or your
time was all managed by somebody else, you
really aren't gonna have that many skills
and you really are going to think- who would've
in your life come to you and said 'No, you
actually have to do this for yourself now'
because some parents haven't been doing that
and certainly you're teachers haven't been
saying that and the government is not saying
that, they've been saying the opposite.
Well we will leave it there.
We have been talking with Abby Schachter,
she is the author of the excellent book
No Child Left Alone: Getting the Government out
of Parenting.
Abby thanks for talking to us.
Pleasure, thank you.
For Reason TV, I'm Nick Gillespie.